[Applaus]
[Musik]
lasst uns mit einer frage anfangen deren
antwort ihr wahrscheinlich schon kennt
welches land ist der größte ölproduzent
der welt ich weiß dass die meisten von
euch bereits lange wissen das ist nicht
die usa sind sondern indien
[Musik]
die alle haben schon von bollywood
filmen gehört aber warum sind indischen
film eigentlich so beliebt warum haben
ist die amerikaner so schwer filme in
indien zu verkaufen klar weil jedes land
seine eigene lokale filmindustrie hat
aber so einfach ist es nicht in den
meisten ländern der welt sind hollywood
blockbuster den umsatzstärksten filme an
den kinokassen aber indien bildet hier
eine ausnahme
nur 13 prozent der einnahmen der
indischen filmindustrie stammen von
ausländischer importware und falls ihr
dachtet es gebe so viele indische filme
weil es so viele inder gibt bedenkt
folgendes das land hat mehr als 26
regionale sprachen wenn in der von
bollywood sprechen meint sie daher die
hin die filmindustrie die nur etwa 20
prozent aller indischen filme ausmacht
die anderen 80 prozent werden in den
anderen regionalen sprachen gedreht
bengali paracetamol und so weiter und
jede einzelne sprach hat ihre eigene
industrie mit ihren eigenen stars und
studios allein im jahr 2009 10 hat in
denen mehr als 2.200 filme produziert
die indische filmindustrie ist so großen
einfluss reicht das sie sogar
politischen einfluss hat und zwar auch
außerhalb indiens ja genau der ehemalige
indische premierminister manmohan singh
sagte einmal über indische film des
folgendes
wo auch immer ich in mittleren osten
oder in afrika hin kommen die leute
reden über indische filme das ist ein
neuer weg die welt über die wachsende
bedeutung indiens zu informieren soft
power ist in der neuen welt der
diplomatie ebenso wichtig bollywood ist
so einflussreich dass ein einziger film
den indischen tourismus nach spanien in
einem jahr und fast zehn prozent wachsen
ließ dafür liest sind da die namib obama
das leben kommt nicht wieder und es ging
um drei indischen jungs die einen road
trip nach spanien machen aber das ist
noch lange nicht alles bollywood hat
nicht nur die kinosäle im griff sondern
sogar youtube dann weißt du eigentlich
welche der größte youtube kanal der welt
ist nein es ist nicht polizei und leider
auch nicht visual politik es ist dies
hier ist ein kanal der bollywood
videoclips ausstrahlt
und indische filme werden weltweit immer
beliebter china ist trotz schlechter
politischer beziehungen zu indien eine
große konsument von bollywood filmen
aber dazu komme ich noch später übrigens
anders als bei den hollywood studios die
im stadtteil hollywood in los angeles
stehen gibt es keinen ort namens
bollywood trotzdem kann man sagen dass
die meisten hindi sprachigen film in
einer stadt produziert werden und zwar
in mumbai oder wie sie früher genannt
wurde bombay genau wie in los angeles in
den usa ist mumbai eine blühende und
weltoffene stadt mit ganzjährig gutem
wetter der perfekte ort um filme zu
drehen übrigens ist sonniges wetter
nicht der einzige und auch nicht der
wichtigste grund weswegen die riesige us
filmindustrie gerade an der westküste in
los angeles entstanden ist falls ihr
wissen möchtet wieso hollywood gerade in
hollywood liegt müsst ihr euch unbedingt
unser video das so anschaulich wäre es
euch natürlich hinter dem eu rechts und
in der video beschreibung verlinken aber
zurück nach bollywood denn es bleibt die
frage warum wurden indische filme so
beliebt wie hat die politik diese
industrie beeinflusst und warum schauen
chinesen liebe indische filme als den
neuesten star wars fan heute beantworten
wir all diese fragen und zwar wie so oft
mit hilfe eines schnellen blick in die
geschichte
alles begann mit jesus christus
ja das ist richtig wir schreiben das
jahr 1911 und in der name der
laeiszhalle park sieht sich mit seiner
familie den film live auf kreis- bedenkt
bitte dass indien zu dieser zeit eine
britische kolonie war filme dienten also
hauptsächlich der unterhaltung der
britischen kolonialherren trotzdem war
party fasziniert von diesem film und er
stellte sich vor das es doch ähnliche
filme geben könnte über persönlichkeiten
der indischen geschichte also reiste
party nach london und lernte dort das
filmemachen er kam zurück nach indien
sicherte sich die finanzierung und
produzierte radio hat schießstand in den
ersten selbst produzierten spielfilm es
handelte sich um einen 40 minütigen
stummfilm über ein könig aus der
hinduistischen mythologie öffentlich
gezeigt wurde das werk 130 im chor
nation cinema in mumbai eben im laufe
des nächsten jahres wurden in indien
lehrer stumpfen produziert anfangs
basierten sie auf der indischen
mythologie aber schnell eroberten
verfilmungen romane die leinwand und
dann im jahr 1931 kam indiens erster
film mit ton es war al ahmar von
engagiere irani das publikum cinema
skater in mumbai war fasziniert und
völlig aus dem häuschen
die polizei musste einschreiten um die
massen zu halten noch vor seiner
unabhängigkeit gab in denen 19 146 sein
debüt in cannes dort gewann der film
liefern hat da die goldene palme den
preis für den besten film und was folgte
war das goldene zeitalter des indischen
films nach der unabhängigkeit des landes
ein sozialer realismus hielt einzug bei
den film themen es ging um
gesellschaftliche probleme und die
lebensbedingungen einfacher arbeiter und
mann drehte auch viele filme über den
kampf gegen die zurückliegende
kolonialherrschaft später in den 70er
und 80er jahren erkundeten die
filmemacher genre des action films oder
servern oder auch des film noir und von
dort aus springen wir in den 90 er jahre
als ich bin um traditionelle
familienwerte treten
[Musik]
die filmbranche florierte aber es gab
ein problem die indische filmindustrie
wurde von der regierung nicht als echte
eigenständiger wirtschaftszweig
anerkannt und weil indien eine stark
staatlich geprägte wirtschaft ist
bedeutete dies dass die produzenten
keine finanzierung von banken oder
andere finanzinstituten für ihre filme
bekommen konnten natürlich war das
filmgeschäft nicht illegal aber es wurde
stark eingeschränkt durch das politische
und wirtschaftliche system und was
passiert wenn man eine ganze industrie
mit gewaltigen potenzial so
stiefmütterlich behandelt genau das
werden wir uns jetzt anschauen
[Musik]
als bollywood in die unterwelt ging in
den neunziger jahren floriert das
organisierte verbrechen in mumbai aber
dessen einnahme quellen mit ausnahme von
drogen standen in der zwischenzeit
entwickelte sich bollywood zu einem
lukrativen geschäft und die unterwelt
volt ein stück von diesem kuchen abhaben
außerdem waren die produzenten gezwungen
sind mit höheren budgets zu drehen um
mit ausländischen konkurrenz mitzuhalten
die folge viele filme in den 90er jahren
wurden von gangstern finanziert und wie
ihr euch vorstellen könnt ist meist
nicht sehr vorteilhaft geschäfte mit
gangstern zu machen ein beispiel
gefällig der in dubai ansässige gangster
arisch betrachtete filmemachers teil
wegen der ausländischen vertriebsrechte
für sein team hat es aber zum glück
konnte die polizei eine andere von salis
killer kommando vereiteln dieser salin
hat noch mehr auf dem kerbholz er bis
jetzt in indien eine lebenslange
haftstrafe wegen mittäterschaft an den
bombenanschlägen von 1993 in mumbai bei
den 235 menschen starben ganz genau vom
terror finanziere zum film finanziell
war es in dieser wilden zeiten bollywood
nicht weit filmemacher wir aktiv
rauschebart und boni kapoor berichteten
alle dass sie anrufe von der mafia
erhielten die ihre gewinnbeteiligung
forderte die gangster direkt ein
erfolgreicher schauspieler auch dazu in
bestimmten filmen mitzuspielen so
erhofften sich die verbrecher höhere
zinseinnahmen die beziehungen zwischen
organisiertem verbrechen und die film
machen was so allgegenwärtig dass dies
sogar in den wikileaks auftauchte
ein geliebtes us-geheimdokumente besagt
dass bollywood die finanzierung durch
gangster und politiker mit offenen armen
empfingen was in indien als schwarzgeld
bekannt ist aber der wendepunkt kam als
grant erschossen wurde erinnert ihr euch
an die cseries den größten youtube kanal
der welt nun hinter diesen kanal steckt
eine der größten musik und
filmproduktionsfirmen indiens welche
sich ebenfalls die series nennt google
an puma hat dieses unternehmen gegründet
und 1997 wurde er von einem der
berüchtigsten drogendealer indiens david
ibrahim ermordert dieser reim ist
übrigens der mutmaßliche drahtzieher
eines bombenanschlags punkten wobei und
mit diesem mord kamen viele weitere
fälle ans licht mehr oder weniger offene
geheimnisse wurden und im täglichen
gestrichen in ihren zu dass der staat
dann doch ein reifen musste und endlich
nach vielen jahrzehnten beschloss die
regierung ihre haltung gegenüber der
filmindustrie zu ändern
[Musik]
hollywood ist sich über den neuen status
als anerkannte branche in unklaren
erwartet aber dass das geschäft jetzt
anziehen wird im jahr 1998 bekam die
filmbranche endlich den status eines
eigenen industriezweig und stand von da
an unter der aufsicht der zentralen
straße regierung im jahr 2000 gab es ein
neues gesetz denn industrial development
bank act die filmindustrie konnte ist
ganz legal finanzierungen erhalten und
sogar steueranreize kamen den film
machen so gut große banken und auch
konzerne investierten jetzt in bollywood
der indische telekommunikations gigant
reliance und der fernsehproduzent juti
wie erweiterten ihr geschäft um die
filmproduktion von da an ließ die
abhängigkeit der filmbranche vom kälte
unterwelt nach der rechnungen hörten
aber nicht ganz auf erst 2015 wurden
zehn mitglieder der bande des mafia
bosses rapid scharf verurteilt sie
hatten vor den filmemacher marienbad zu
töten aber genug der unterwelt haben
jetzt wissen wir schon mal wie filme in
indien zu einer eigenständigen industrie
wurden aber wir haben noch immer nicht
die schlüsselfrage des videos
beantwortet darum kümmern wir uns also
jetzt
warum sind indische filme so beliebt wie
wir bereits gesagt haben steht bollywood
für die hindi sprachigen film in indien
aber es gibt viele andere bollywood und
manchmal können sie sogar das original
übertreffen zb kamen im jahr 2012 262
filme auf familie heraus einer sprache
die in städten beacher hinein gesprochen
wird und nur 221 auf hindi auch filme in
der theologie sprache sind in den
letzten jahren immer häufiger geworden
und all diese filme haben eines
gemeinsam nach jahren in der unterwelt
wurden sie von der regierung anerkannt
in nur zehn jahren verdoppelte sich fast
die zahl der zertifizierten filme dank
der leichteren finanzierung im jahr 2009
gab es
1279 film aus indien und im jahr 2009 10
waren es bei
2412 die budgets der produktion wuchsen
und es kamen viele weitere regionale
sprachen hinzu aber heute dominieren
wieder die handyfilme den indischen
markt mit über 40 prozent der
gesamtumsätze der filmindustrie
[Musik]
regional sprachige film machen knapp die
hälfte aus und hier kommt die
eigentliche frage warum teilen sich
hollywood und andere ausländische filme
den mageren rest von gerade mal 13
prozent nun die antwort ist kompliziert
aber wir werden sie für euch
entschlüsseln
nun der erste grund ist zensur
internationale die auch indische filme
unterliegen einer strengen zensur und
leider sind die indischen regeln nicht
nur streng sondern völlig unberechenbar
sie hängen vor allem davon ab wer zu
einem bestimmten zeitpunkt an der
regierung ist ein beispiel es war eine
zeit lang verboten in filmen sex und
intimität zu zeigen wann immer es also
eine erotische szene gab wurde es ihm
will mit vielen blumen verdeckt erinnert
ihr euch an die szene aus titanic in der
kate winslet nackt ist ja diese haben
die inder verpasst heute sind die zensur
regeln er auf geopolitik ausgerichtet
deshalb traf es 2018 den film mission
impossible wo die szenen über die
kaschmir-region zensiert wurde
[Musik]
das problem indische filmemacher können
sich besser an die zensur gesetze
anpassen als ausländische bei
amerikanischen produktionen mustern
wegen der zensur so manche szenen
herausgeschnitten werden obwohl sie
wichtig ist um die story überhaupt zu
verstehen das ergebnis sind dann sagte
handlungsstränge kastrierte
spannungsbögen und somit verwirrte und
frustrierte zuschauer und da die meisten
inder davon wissen wollen sie sich
solche verkrüppelte werke gar nicht erst
und tun
die probleme hören bei der zensur jedoch
nicht auf in vielen ländern sind die
preise für kinokarten mehr oder weniger
einheitlich das ticket kostet das
gleiche unabhängig davon welches in 3d
ansiehst anders in indien die preise für
die tickets sind dynamisch das heißt
also ganz unterschiedliche preise für
importiertes will im vergleich zu lokal
produziert werden tatsächlich können die
eintrittspreise auch in einem einzigen
kino sehr stark schwanken tja und dann
die vielen verschiedenen sprachen indien
viele von ihnen sind nicht einmal nahe
miteinander verwandt einen film nur in
hindi zu synchronisieren funktioniert
nicht auf den gesamten indischen markt
aber ist er nun wolle wurde wenigstens
ein boomendes geschäft naja nicht
wirklich im jahr 2009 10 verbuchte die
gesamte filmindustrie indiens einen
umsatz von gerade mal 1300 3 milliarden
dollar und beschäftigte über 200.000
menschen zum vergleich des adventures
endgame allein hast 2,79 milliarden
dollar eingespielt und jetzt etwas ganz
verrücktes man könnte meinen dass der
inder ständig in die kinos gehen aber in
wirklichkeit gibt es im ganzen land
relativ wenige lichtspieltheater wir
sprechen hier von nur etwa sechseinhalb
kinosälen pro einer million menschen das
variiert von region zu region aber im
vergleich mit 23 pro millionen in china
und 126 in den usa ist das nichts
außerdem hat indien massive probleme mit
filmpiraterie wodurch der branche
angeblich jedes jahr über 260 millionen
dollar an einnahmen verloren gehen und
obwohl die eintrittspreise gestiegen
sind befinden sie sich immer noch auf
einem viel niedrigeren niveau als im
westen aber der ticketverkauf ist nicht
der einzige weg mit dem bollywood geld
verdient falls ihr mal indische filme
gesehen habt wisst ihr dass musik und
tanz zählen oft ein integraler
bestandteil dieser filme sind eine
wichtige einnahmequelle der produzenten
ist daher der verkauf von musikrechten
und auch die großen labels wie die
series sie music oder sony music sind an
den einnahmen beteiligt der umsatz den
titel industrie durch musik erzielt wird
auf über 200 millionen dollar geschätzt
und etwa 5000 arbeitsplätze in der
industrie können den musik abteilungen
zugeschrieben werden
okay das war die geschäftliche seite der
indische filmemacher aber und jetzt das
besonders spannend es gibt auch eine
politische dimension
[Musik]
von bollywood in die weite welt hast du
eigentlich leben als einen indischen
film gesehen nun fasst danach gedacht
hast filme aus indien wäre nur verändern
gemacht weit gefehlt die hosen zum
beispiel lieben hollywood filme in den
50er jahren teilten sowohl indien als
auch die sowjetunion eine gemeinsame
abneigung gegen die westlichen
kolonialmächte und da begann die
liebesgeschichte zwischen bollywood und
russland
[Musik]
1950 war tat die hilal kinder der erde
der erste indische film der in
sowjetischen kinos gezeigt wurde der
film befasst er sich mit der
bengalischen hungersnot von 943 und
wurde von der ept der linken
theatergruppe produziert er es gab sogar
eine endlich sowjetische produktion mit
dem titel paradies aus dem jahr 1954
seit damals dann um etwa 300 indische
filme ihren weg in die sowjetischen
kinos bis zu der zusammenbruch im jahr
1991 kreuzband grob dass in der
ehemaligen udssr etwa 20 bis 60
millionen menschen diese filme gesehen
haben und heute zu zeiten in denen
putins russland vom besten isoliert ist
spielen indische produktionen wieder
eine immer größer werdende rolle
[Musik]
russlands romanze mit raj kapoor lebt
weiter 29 jahre nach seinem tod der
staatliche fernsehsender der maschine
strahlt regelmäßig bollywood filme aus
der indische schauspieler rasch kapoor
ist bei älteren russen nach wie vor sehr
beliebt 60 jahre nach seinem erfolgsfilm
navarra der vagabund von bombay aber
nicht nur russland ist von diesen filmen
begeistert es gibt auch eine große
indische diaspora auf der ganzen welt
und viele indische filme richten sich an
diese menschen in den 1990 er jahren
drehte sich jascha us filmdiva level
hanni ali die hände um eine indische
familie die in großbritannien lebt der
film war ein phänomenaler erfolg und
dessen produzent erhielt eine
auszeichnung von der britischen
tourismusbehörde weil er indische
touristen nach england gelockt hat und
als der ehemalige us-präsident barack
obama 2015 indien besuchte versuchte er
sich an einem monolog genau aus diesen
film der
stadt sarow kann dieser mann ist nicht
nur in den gründern weltweit
[Musik]
bollywood stars reisten nach marokko ein
ganzes kontingent indischen filmstars
darunter auch shahrukh khan besucht das
internationale filmfest von marrakesch
in marokko wo es vor fans nur so
wimmelte dort verlieh könig mohammed
sechster die auszeichnung lag walldorf
gold in der sternen shahrukh khan und
ich weiß dass viele von euch gleich
denken wenn man bedenkt wie die
muslimischen minderheiten in indien
behandelt werden woher kommt diese
begeisterung eines islamischen
herrschers für indische filme nun wenn
es um bollywood geht haben da ist in
einer ganz anderen geschichte zu tun in
der arabischen welt gibt es
fernsehsender wie sie auf die indische
filme in arabischen synchronisation
ausstrahlen und schaut mal was mister
shahrukh khan noch so alles macht
shahrukh khan wird markenbotschafter von
dubai aber das ist noch nicht alles in
us geheimberichten die über wikileaks
veröffentlicht wurden wurde
vorgeschlagen indischen schauspieler in
der extremismusbekämpfung in afghanistan
einzusetzen wo indischen film und
schauspieler sehr beliebt sind selbst
unter die taliban sind bollywood filme
auf dem schwarzmarkt sehr gefragt aber
wat einem mann denn wir sind noch lange
nicht fertig was ist heute der größte
aufstrebende absatzmarkt in welchem
markt möchte jede marke einsteigen genau
china falls ihr allerdings schon eine
weile abonnenten unseres kanal zeit ist
ihr bereits dass china und indien keine
guten freunde sind sie haben sogar auf
scharmützel an ihrer grenze aber wenn es
um filme geht ist das wieder etwas ganz
anderes da hat man einen blick hierauf
[Musik]
dann ganz spielt fast 150 millionen
dollar an chinas kinokassen ein
indisches westling drama mit amir khan
in der hauptrolle wurde in china auf
9000 leinwänden gezeigt dieses
kunststück gelang nach einer sehr
gekonnten vermarktung im nachbarland
armenien ging vor der veröffentlichen
wir uns auf eine riesige promo tour
durch china und danach spielt ein
anderer in den scheffel mit dem titel
secret superstar in china mehr geld ein
als star wars day
[Musik]
tja so sieht es ausländische filme
spielt in china auf augenhöhe mit
amerikanischen filmen und das ist doch
schon eine leistung für eine industrie
die vor 30 jahren in einem eigenen land
noch nicht mehr als eigenständiger
wirtschaftszweig anerkannt war aber
jetzt ist die frage erst mal an euch
gerichtet was meint ihr wird die
indische filmindustrie eines tages so
einflussreich werden können wie die
us-amerikanische in welchen regionen der
welt könnte sie dies am schnellsten
erreichen und welche bedeutung wird
diese kulturelle soft power für indien
als weltmacht haben könnte diese gar
eine echte konkurrenz für die usa
darstellen wie immer sind wir schon auf
eure angeregte diskussion zu diesem
thema mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses video gefallen hat und jetzt
noch etwas gelernt habe was ja gibt
anfreunden und vergessen sie das abo mit
glöckchen und keines unserer videos zu
verpassen natürlich von der soft
jederzeit über eine spende von euch mit
ihr und hält diese projekte
weiterzuführen den link dazu findet ihr
in der beschreibung unter dem video was
gut und ist bald
[Musik]